All right, I want to sort of get ahead of
this story and spend some time today talking
about supposed Biden mask mandates, because
the amount of disinformation that we're already
seeing, if it's at all a preview, is going
to absolutely explode when Joe Biden is actually
sworn in as president of the United States
on January 20th.
So to go back a little bit, right wingers
have been warning even during the campaign,
Joe Biden will lock everyone in their homes.
Joe Biden will be a dictator with masks and
all sorts of other things if he becomes president.
And over the last 48 to 72 hours, we heard
two different things that are not the same
thing.
Very important.
We heard from Dr. Anthony Fauci that indeed,
Joe Biden plans to do a 100 day mask initiative.
And within that, there will be a peace that
is a federal mask mandate.
Now, when you hear a federal mask mandate,
many people imagine something that is very
different from what we're actually going to
get.
So let me say this in the clearest terms possible,
Joe Biden nor any president can mandate a
national mask wearing a law where everybody's
forced to wear a mask outside of their homes.
I've already addressed that.
So listen very closely to what I'm going to
say.
What Joe Biden can do is address the nation
from the Oval Office and ask people to wear
masks.
He can call the governors of 50 states and
ask them to put in place mask mandates, which
governors can do in various areas.
Massachusetts Governor Charlie Baker is an
example.
Earlier this week, he's a Republican, announced
that there will be a massive mandate in workplaces
in Massachusetts.
We got an email from our office tenant where
everybody's working from home anyway right
now, but they said everybody's got to wear
a mask per Charlie Bakers order.
Governors can do that given states rights.
And yet there's a ton of headlines today which
are very confusing in talking about a Joe
Biden nationwide mask mandate suggesting the
federal government will force everybody to
wear a mask.
So let me explain what's going on.
As the president of the United States, part
of the federal government, Joe Biden, plans
to issue a mask mandate that includes federal
buildings as well as airplanes, trains and
busses which are regulated by the federal
Department of Transportation.
That's it.
That's the mandate, that's what the president
can do via executive order, and in just about
every state, masks are already required in
all of those places.
Now, I do have some federal government employee
friends who work in red states who have told
me, you know, the the equivalent agency in
Massachusetts and in California, you've got
to wear a mask in my office for that same
agency in a red state.
Our boss is not mandated masks that will change
based on this mask mandate for federal buildings,
but it will change very little else.
So before we go crazy misstating what this
is, Joe Biden's mandate will apply only to
federal buildings and transportation vehicles
regulated by the DOT.
Beyond that, any mass guidelines from Biden
will merely be guidelines.
They will be requests.
They will be proposals.
It will be up to your governor to decide what
to do.
That's it.
Now, Dr. Foushee has said wearing masks for
100 days is a good idea.
It will be up to the people and governors
ultimately to decide what it is they want
to do.
For people who have been wearing masks for
months already, this is going to be much ado
about nothing.
Consider that, you know, there is now a light
at the end of the tunnel.
Let's actually work together to start getting
past this.
If we can start.
Here's my trajectory.
If we can start vaccinating five to seven
percent of our population each month, maybe
that includes December.
Maybe we only get, you know, one, two percent
done in December.
In January, we get five to seven percent February,
etc..
This means in six months we could have somewhere
between 30 and 40, two percent of the population
vaccinated, plus the five to 10 percent who
will have recovered from the virus.
We don't yet know how uniform immunity is
when you recover.
There's the idea that if you have a very light
case, your immunity may not be as robust as
if you recover from a more serious case.
So we don't know exactly, but we could be
heading towards roughly 50 percent level of
immunity by May 1st, maybe by May 15th.
That won't be the end, but it will be a dramatically
better situation.
We will also likely at that point have cheap
at home tests.
So like for me, if I imagine, hey, I might
be able to order 50 or 100 of these cheap
at home rapid tests.
I've been very cautious, but I've continued
going to the grocery store.
I go to the post office during the summer.
I was hanging out outdoors with friends, eating
outdoors at restaurants.
If we had on May 15th, May 1st, May 15th,
50 percent immunity and these at home tests,
I would likely be ready to say, for example,
hey, here's a group of six friends we've all
been working from home.
If we all do a rapid test, I would be comfortable
if we're all negative, hanging out indoors,
maintaining a reasonable amount of distance,
assuming we're at 50 percent immunity with
these tests.
OK, I mean, listen, it's not perfect, but
we're talking about May, June.
And to be clear, with half the country vaccinated
now, you also have to remember there is a
lag time on vaccination immunity.
And what I mean by that is the time until
vaccinated people actually reduce the number
of deaths could is weeks.
And what I mean by that is on day one, you
get dose number one dose.
No one confers some immunity, but not all.
So that starts to have an effect day.
Twenty to twenty one days later, you get your
second dose and then seven days after that,
you would be considered to be, you know, there's
a ninety five percent chance that you were
immune.
So by day twenty eight to twenty nine, you
ideally are no longer getting other people
sick who you might have gotten sick were you
not vaccinated since it takes 20 days in general
from when someone catches the virus to when
they die, if they're going to die vaccinated,
individuals will not be fully effective at
reducing deaths for forty eight days.
We won't see the impact on deaths of a vaccinated
individual for up to forty eight days.
Now we know that after dose one you can be
as much as 70 or even 75 percent likely to
be immune.
So these are all confidence intervals.
But I think you understand the point that
there's a lag time before which vaccination
is not really doing doing that much to stop
cases and to stop deaths.
So the point is this is a process.
And there is every indication that by May
one, May 15, we will be in a better situation.
Masks will likely be required in just as many
places as they are today.
But we are now.
We had twenty nine hundred sixty people die
yesterday, were essentially at a 9/11 every
day.
So rather than the point is, rather than lying
about what Joe Biden plans to do, let's work
together and start getting past this.